TobiWan: Jump up, perfect from Miracle-!
With the Meld strike.
Miracle- ahh, he actually gets away.
22 life, the TA trap will slow him down.
He wants to deny himself in the corner. Cuts through!
And actually Blinks himself into the other side
of the tree-line! They don't see him! They don't know!
scantzor: A lot of teams have added these new, young, flashy
really skilled players who
have excelled in ranked games.
And Miracle- is, like,
the epitome of that.
ODPixel: There's your Avalanche, here's
the backup and the rest of the stun.
He will get off the Crimson Guard. But what does it matter?
He just gets destroyed by Miracle-.
scantzor: There's been so much talk for the last few
months about how talented this guy is.
ODPixel: Is he going to head into the pit?
Oh this could be big. Just as it's about to expire.
He's got the Requiem on two!
OH MY GOD MIRACLE-!
GoDz: There's a reason he's going to be
our first 9k MMR player.
TobiWan: He will go down.
Tinker's the man to find that kill.
But they're looking for more!
Miracle- comboing up. The big Deafening Blast!
A double Deafening Blast!
Sunder will save Raven!
But it won't save the rest of his team!
Eul's Scepter spinning him 'round.
He'll just keep hitting up.
Is he ever gonna hit the ground right now?
...the sideline, buyback is available.
But PieLieDie is on the run, the Homing Missile chasing him.
But EnVy! Miracle-!
Just 'noms all over him.
Blitz: Push out all the lanes before Liquid
can get inside the base.
But they're gonna meet their creep wave here!
Capitalist: The buybacks are up, 15 seconds,
20 seconds on the Brewmaster.
MATUMBAMAN takes a lot of damage here
but Miracle-...HE GETS MATUMBAMAN!
Miracle- takes him solo!
LD: He could go onto SumaiL here
who Skewers back over the high ground.
But Miracle- was waiting!
He caught him off! All 8,000 MMR!
what are the supporting the boys what
are you gonna do they have to go to get
there it only lasts longer to load for
the facts on the dance floor well it's
gonna be good at empty let it be found a
table gonna surprise for you boy you
supposed to be hunting w well first of
all pts taken down to third the question
is camera for Kerry will be fucked 305
come on taking your own special canopy
and every size of a star so you can have
a lot of miracles gonna dump me those
with your freakin great the makeup was
bearing down Danny feels like they
probably defective brake such as well
yeah the ages i moving too fast traffic
star 450 and they should be departing
the physical started before it takes to
get across to get together with all
their most people don't know you're
really do another one going to do it you
can let your dog good is the document on
table
not even to the forces of my ex he's
gonna run to the RTV against the elusive
stopping
yep very well played John from off the
green VA but it's real
no just america's energy coming to the
ground and help him adjust the camera
before we slide shops out on a walk now
understand miracle he spent for the push
is the biggest structural damage you
might not get it again with the waveform
miracle getting up an hour late but
general here was today they weren't
ready for the extra extra support hero
and miracles on the run your waveform
does have a little more charges miracle
just jump in if you really want to
quickly to prevent that dashboard huge
impact the water and other three two
baby baby but he's having all these
steps all the way from miracle that
pretty much the end of the game right
there three throws out in one hell of a
year if there's a while couple weeks and
he won the spirit trouble the miracles
and trying to keep up with the right to
say America to find the killer
thank you for sprint down to make a call
to 156 nobody's going to get out well
someone kill 4rg with your boy hold on
the go
yes correct carried by itself for the
stuff like to walk careful Sophie the
bottle will take down where's the
freaking was happening front-of-house
staff without very / Trek America triple
kelly faircloth live cause quite feel
invincible America but Americans have to
play cows are you missed the invasion
don't want to go to that of technical
might actually thought anyway the right
leg splints together house lots of
miracles all related documents or he got
always oh my god
you may already know haha people talk
about what are you going to the career
haha what for the Japanese never gonna
get it all up
he doesn't boot with top of my car
you're really for my god very specific
tool available and will call the Alterra
to that concept from CA might get your
50 tricky like us with not heal
important factor in your shoes your
mouth their first take any but isn't it
up because looking for the fact you
Boudreaux fat as well if the triple kill
for miracles steps towards the last one
next alike they take the papal the fact
that the stolen extra cookie tracking us
feedback ultra kill for maracle's
ceiling board is actually keeping the so
healthy spiritual slowed down we're
going to go for that happy they want to
actually fly touji but it's not quite
healthy enough to fully commit here now
see free going to be chopped away by
miracle chetty he's up to slow down
state rock-and-roll escapes whatsoever
from on
get the old step there just to make sure
there's no real opening American of a
game of us now be careful if you Sonic
illmerica it may not go according to
matt got yet
look out if you might want to do this
obvious similarities my cat lady look at
here is 53 to tell the doctor example if
to see everything is VDC now that
finally did 17 income Americans think
i'm going to not kill the time to check
out my diagraph pictures online as well
as giving signs to feel entitled sighs
don't control miracles have to be
consistent whether you're not going to
try it sounds like we just go for it to
be talking about what is important is
beyond the class on the other main wall
lift he's watching helplessly unable to
save TV was gonna have to play around
and found wait for little trained
Stephen the safety brother reason you've
got the whole ready to go they can
actually be here for the weekend off the
only board
somebody stop that what does into the
trade to the little kiddies joking that
was announced window belly is less a
load against America q-ball inventory
time and time again but miracles like
you anymore 0 does style onmyo thanks
for watching if you want more great
content be sure to hit that subscribe